Welcome to the final act of Metal Gear Solid 4.
The final act with our beloved Solid Old Snake.
The last time I get to play as him... in his story.
Yeah, watch Long Incoming, true.
So true, so true.
I don't want it to switch to the... what's it called?
The commercials.
Keep listening to Old Snake theme.
There will be a lot of cutscenes today, so if you are not prepared...
Maybe, depending on how we're feeling, before some of them we'll do like a brief potty break.
And then get into it.
We're prepared to cry, we're prepared to cry!
Yeah, a bit of an intermission.
Thanks for getting me hooked on MGS Boss so hype!
I'm still not ready though.
I'm still not ready.
I ate my snack during intermissions.
I have my popcorn.
I got a new... I went to the store earlier to get popcorn.
I got a new popcorn.
Never gotten it before.
Because popcorn I usually get was like so expensive.
Even on sale, it was like $5.
I was like, I don't remember it being this expensive.
And I got the store brand one for $1.50.
Let's test it.
Let's see how it tastes.
I got kettle corn.
What flavor is kettle corn?
Kettle corn.
Alright.
Let's see if it has a good crunch.
It's like not sweet at all.
Hold on, maybe that was a bad one.
Okay, okay, it's pretty good.
Okay, it's pretty good.
Yeah, it's pretty good.
Yeah, it tastes pretty good.
Worth saving the money.
She said the thing.
I should be going to bed now.
So I'm not a zombie, I work tomorrow, but I'm making a stream.
No!
Salkind, this is going to be a very long stream.
You should go to sleep, or you could go to sleep while watching.
Go to sleep.
And last time we did some spirit photography.
Look, we exercised these.
There was a ghost here, and it's gone now.
And there was a ghost here.
Oh, there's still a ghost here.
There is a ghost here.
It's gone now.
There's a ghost here.
It's funny, my controller does like a tiny little vibration.
And then we took some sexy photos.
Oh yeah.
Awesome.
Why do I sound like that?
You're too invested.
And exit.
Look at that.
Oh yeah.
She looks cold.
She looks too cold.
Oh gosh, that's a spooky ghost.
Just like me.
Sounds like Lay Your Love On Me by ABBA.
Oh, it kind of does.
It is.
Wait.
What part does it sound like?
I hear it.
Goodbye Baker.
Death by IBS.
Wait, is this?
Oh, that's Baker too.
No place for Hideo.
Okay, I'm not going to do all of them.
Does exercising the ghost do anything?
I think you get DP from it.
No?
Or you get DP when you... I can't remember.
When you take the picture.
I can't remember.
Rudy, thank you for 10 months!
What's the policy on birthday songs this stream?
Asking with zero pressure.
Rusa!
That's a great question actually.
I think I will sing birthday songs.
Up until...
Maybe Microwave Halloway.
What if we exercise all the ghosts?
Once you have to end the stream and go...
Outside!
Yeah,
I think the real turning point is...
The feeling of the game...
Happens at the hallway.
So I think...
I think up until then.
That's when the real tonal shift...
I mean, there's already been a tonal shift.
But you know what I mean.
But anyway, I can sing happy birthday for you right now!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Rusa!
Happy birthday!
And also, maybe probably during some...
Cutscenes, you know.
Depending.
Great question though.
If you do have a birthday...
And you would like for me to sing it...
Did you change the PS3 clock back to...
I didn't!
I
didn't change it back!
Quit the game.
David, you saved me.
Oh my gosh!
We have it set to Monday.
Let me see.
Date and time setting.
Wait.
It says 23rd.
Maybe I did set it back.
I just don't remember.
I guess I did do it.
I must have done it directly after stream.
And completely forgot.
Funny.
Yeah,
exactly!
That's what we're talking about.
On Sundays and...
Not Mondays.
Sundays and Wednesdays.
Okay.
Cool.
When did I change it back?
My PS3 is haunted.
The darker color and the eyepatch go well together.
Yeah!
Thank you!
I thought that it kind of like...
Gives like a sneaking suit sort of vibe.
An AI did it.
Oh my gosh, the Patriots.
Sasuga, the Patriots!
Sheesh.
Oh gosh.
I'm...
Nervous.
But...
We'll just get into it, because...
Not so much talking, so we can just...
Like I said, it'll be quite a...
Quite a longer stream.
Today, we should be able to get...
The...
I will try to get the sorrow doll.
Since I don't have that.
Of the mantis doll.
But...
We can get the...
The gun!
Ready for the final act of MGS4...
In the world record part of the game!
I actually got real leftover movie popcorn.
You got this, Mint.
Thanks, Chikaido!
Chikaido!
I can never remember how to do that fight.
You know, I watched a fight...
Thing last week, and I can't remember either.
So much has happened this week for me...
That my brain is...
A little jumbled.
But I do remember there's one...
Way to cheese...
Part of the fight that happens before.
But I think I'll just do it properly.
I probably won't go with...
Very many cheeses.
Because...
I know also...
Before I talked about farming...
Or drubbing points.
Because there's a place in here...
That you can.
But obviously...
I just want to get through the game.
And...
So...
No cheese, zero lactose.
I'm feeling...
Lactose intolerance.
There is.
Can you show it at least?
What, the cheese for the fight?
It's not the fight for Mantis.
That's not a spoiler, obviously.
We know that we have to fight...
The last boss babe beauty.
Beast.
Boss beast.
Beauty beast.
But there's a little fight before it.
Basically I can kind of explain it.
So there is a bunch of...
There's like several rounds of...
Froggies.
Froggy girls that come in.
But on the first round of the froggies...
You...
You get it down to one last frog.
And then you basically just kind of...
Keep her in a...
Stun grenade loop.
And...
Eventually...
It like, I don't remember...
I don't remember if it's like a...
If you...
Run out of time?
Like if the game automatically moves on?
Or if you have to do something.
That's why I'm not going to attempt it because I don't quite remember.
But you...
Um...
Eventually the game is just like...
Okay, you spent enough time with the frogs.
Time for the next fight.
And you...
Can skip the whole other rounds.
Of the...
Of it, so yeah.
Sorry, I'm not good at explaining things.
I'm not good at explaining things.
Another birthday!
Happy MGS Sunday Minto!
Yesterday was my golden birthday.
What's a golden birthday?
So maybe I get a special MGS happy birthday.
Happy lads, Minky.
Let's finish the snake journey.
BOLD NOODLE!
HAPPY BIRTHDAY!
WAIT, ANOTHER BIRTHDAY!
Twelve!
What do you mean you were too shy?
Can I give her the pink by the way?
What's a golden birthday?
Golden birthday is when you're the same age as the day.
You get a special shower that day.
So I would have been ten...
No, ten.
Sorry, that's the month.
Wait, I died.
So if I was dead for one year, then that would have been my golden death day.
I was basically...
Like, I was basically...
Like, just a speck of light.
What the hell?
So I couldn't even get to celebrate my golden death day.
That's messed up.
Yeah, I was just like a speck.
I was basically like a little tiny spirit.
A spark.
That's so unfair!
I need a redo.
Okay, singing...
Oh wait, I forgot.
I was gonna do Metal Gear versions for this.
Okay.
Happy birthday, congratulations.
Happy birthday, with salutations.
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Bolt noodle, happy birthday!
One more time!
Happy birthday, congratulations.
Happy birthday, with salutations.
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Chidamcha!
Happy birthday!
Alrighty.
Are you guys ready?
Are you guys ready, Freddy?
We have the briefing.
We didn't do the briefing last week.
So we have the briefing for Act 5.
And...
Yeah.
Did you know the melody for that is actually the Zanzibar Land Anthem?
I do actually.
I feel like I've heard that before.
I don't remember hearing the song though, when I played it.
Zanzibar Land.
Okidoki.
Outer Haven.
Mission... briefing.
You can only hear it in one room at certain times.
I guess I missed it.
It's like he's holding his baby.
Maybe not.
This is as fast as she'll go.
Liquid's target is J.D., a U.S.
military satellite disguised as orbital debris.
Haven will have to surface in order to use the railgun.
If we can figure out J.D.'s orbit...
Oh, sorry.
This is probably...
Oh my god.
J.D.
is an asynchronous elliptical orbit.
So its next perigee should be in...
Got it!
15 hours, 6 minutes, and 12 seconds.
Right.
In 15 hours, it's going to be over the Bering Sea.
494 nautical miles from the Bering Strait.
Haven knows it too.
They'll be holding positions in that area.
Did they really have to get that close to launch?
The nukes fired by Rex's railgun have a damage radius of approximately 300 meters.
The target is a moving satellite that's traveling at 10 kilometers per second.
To get the precision they need, they have to get as close as they possibly can.
Liquid won't launch his nuke until J.D.
is at perigee.
The Missouri can use that time to catch up.
Will we make it?
It's closed.
He's out of oxygen.
You'll need to use a railgun mounted on the bridge to destroy J.D.
You'll need to open the cover to launch the nuke.
That's our one and only chance to get inside.
Inside?
Why can't we attack it from here?
It wouldn't do any good.
As long as Liquid has control of the system, physically destroying G.W.
would still leave supreme authority in his hands.
Sons of the Patriots.
Crazy, this is the first time Otacon and Merrill have been in the same room together.
But they were both at Shadow Moses originally.
Star Wars reference.
Everyone is just like...
This man...
Gets me every time.
I can't catch the nerve of that man.
H.R.
H.R.?
He's just like, I might die this mission.
Better get a feel.
Microwaves?
The music.
I know, he's not joking.
Don't say her name.
I think we got that.
I think we understood that.
I'm glad Snake gets it.
Oh, never mind, sorry.
I don't want to... Sorry.
Jump scare.
Attention.
Listen up.
A wise man once wrote...
Tongues of dying men enforce attention like deep harmony.
Where words are spent, they are seldom spent in vain.
Any other questions?
She tried.
Yes, Snake?
Anybody got a smoke?
This guy.
Snake!
Let my man smoke.
He's only got two left.
So this program...
You're saying Sunny wrote it?
Actually, only about a third of it is her work.
Naomi was working on a program to destroy GW.
But she couldn't quite finish it.
So she handed it over to Sunny.
Sunny is a better genius...
Sorry, I don't care.
I don't care about the money.
I just don't want to see Naomi.
Eventually, she found some.
It was Emma's worm cluster.
Look at him helping him.
Emma...
And even the music.
The glasses.
I know, right?
He's better than Emma's.
Sunny's worm destroys the AI's intellect by triggering apoptosis in the cells.
Once uploaded into GW, it should do some real damage.
Even now, she can help us.
Snake, you ever think about quitting?
Why?
It's not like I've got my health to worry about.
He couldn't even take it out.
He couldn't even take it out of his neck.
So awful.
Why don't we get somebody else to go?
There's no need for you to do it.
I still have things left to do.
Besides smoke.
Somebody stop him.
There's no self control.
Otacon, why don't you jump off the ship with me?
I don't think so.
I've still got things to do myself.
And I don't even smoke.
He wants Otacon to come with him.
Yeah, it's totally the nicotine that's going to kill him.
You should be off this boat.
Old Sun.
The final act.
I never used the syringes before in this game, so the syringes didn't happen.
You...what?
It's like part of the game though.
She's so cool.
Aye aye captain.
Aye captain.
Old Sun is rude.
It's only a billion years old.
Captain?
Yes?
This is my first real engagement.
I see.
Your point?
At first, getting assigned to this ship was a big letdown for me.
But the inaction was kind of a relief too.
Okay.
Your point?
Captain, I'm scared.
It's okay.
I'm scared too.
This is also my first time.
But I'm not going to let it get to me.
Because I'm more scared of what will happen if I run away.
Nobody is going to die on my watch.
This ship is going back to Hawaii in one piece.
That, I promise.
Right.
Thank you.
Mei Ling is so cool.
In one piece.
The team!
That
guy.
Final mission.
Raiden.
How is he?
He'll live.
But he's in no shape to fight.
Tell Raiden.
Best to let him rest.
Right.
Without the system to protect them, everybody is losing their nerve.
They say S.O.P.'s after effects are so bad that a lot of soldiers are deserting.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Their nanomachines are...
The only one left to rely on is Marilyn.
Him.
Kind of an unknown fatty, isn't he?
I hooked him up with a non-IDM82.
Fancy meeting you here.
What are you doing here?
Johnny is such a horndog.
I laundered these guys' IDs.
Then issued them new naked weapons.
Including that catapult you're going to be riding.
Business has been slow ever since Liquid got his hands on the system.
His extra orders stopped coming in.
Sir, you're caffeine addiction.
Now that all the weapons all over the world are locked, the only ones still looking to fight would be you and yours.
They tell me it's not economical to replace all that useless equipment on the battlefield with my stuff.
So I made an extra special trip out here, just for you.
And you're gonna give me an extra special?
Discount.
I like Drebin because...
Well, sometimes I like him.
He has no business being here.
He's like Naomi, but he doesn't try to make himself the main character.
He's just kind of curious what's going on.
The pose, I know.
He's like, hey, snake, I can do it too.
Indirect kiss with Drebin?
Okay, indirect kiss with...
You just give it to the monkey instead.
The monkey also has a caffeine addiction.
Both of them.
They need to get... Lay off the... The guy has his own...
The guy has his own...
Vending machine.
How'd he do that?
Magic.
He's a wizard.
It's his last one.
The monkey is like, give me... I also have a nicotine addiction.
Don't give it to him, snake!
Don't!
Have you.
Snake can't even enjoy a last cigarette.
You're welcome.
Oh my god.
Yeah, let's get going.
You're over there.
There.
What she said.
That's what she said.
Yeah, it is animal abuse.
Snake, can you hear me?
Liquid's warship, Outer Haven, is a modified version of an Arsenal Gear model stolen from the Patriots.
Arsenal Gear.
Inside, it's crawling with Irving and other unmanned weapons.
According to Naomi's data, Haven is crewed by a battalion of enhanced soldiers, each called from the best the PMCs have to offer.
If Liquid succeeds in destroying JD and gaining control of the Patriots' system, he'll make Haven his flagship, and his PMCs will spread like wildfire across the globe.
Here he comes!
And then, mankind's armed subjugation will begin.
He's huge.
I'm nervous.
That's mean.
That thing is so big.
Oh my gosh.
Listen closely.
This is our last chance to stop Liquid from enslaving the planet.
So they were gonna make Arsenal Gear just like a long turd.
Instead, they made it into a turd.
Meryl, can you hear me?
It's time.
Time to do your duty.
Remember, no matter what happens, I'll be with you till the very end.
You are my pride and joy.
She's so cool.
She's so cool, even with the nanomachines being turned off.
She's so strong.
Is he deliberately Lucifer-coded?
Possibly.
This game has a lot of religious imagery.
It's the Railgun!
There it is.
A naked nuke.
Let's finish it, Snake.
Let this be our last battle.
If we are responsible for Liquid's sins, then the onus is ours to bear.
Right.
Enemy moving to intercept!
Maintain full speed!
Be careful!
Failure will spell doom for the human race.
No pressure!
You will have to stop them from using that Railgun.
Then annihilate GW.
It feels so like...
It feels so scary coming from Colonel.
It feels too scary coming from him.
That's a lot of missiles.
Nice.
That's not good.
Oh gosh.
This is basically a movie.
Don't worry, we are going to play the game...
Soon.
Oh gosh.
It hasn't been an hour.
Don't worry.
That
doesn't sound good.
It's our turn too!
Oh gosh.
That's
our cue!
Evangelion launch.
I mean Snake Launching.
Alright, it's our turn!
Oh gosh.
Those catapults must be hard on the core.
Don't say that.
The sounds are so spooky.
Oh my gosh.
They are so spooky.
How is everyone more fragile than Snake?
Yeah.
Let me hit it because I'm goofy.
Thank you so much for the 20.
Meryl!
Oh!
I watched the 86 Transformers movie last night.
Surprised to see Paul Eiding's name in the credits.
Oh really?
Uh oh.
Retro!
Uh oh!
If they were shooting at him, does that not mean they saw him?
No?
Okay.
Alright, hold on.
Before we...
Yay!
Everything is half off, baby!
So how much is everything then?
2,500,000.
We're still not even...
Oh my gosh, we're still so far.
It's still so much.
Thank you for the super chat, Duke.
Appreciate it.
Alright, let me set up my... Let's set up my weapons too.
Alright, so we're gonna be using this M82A2.
For sure.
I do know that.
I will be not using the railgun.
Instead, we'll use our pistol.
I'll even grab...
Maybe this.
I don't know how much I'll be sniping to be honest, but...
Well, unless we use the twin barrel.
The farming is not quite yet.
But I don't think I'll be doing it on this stream.
Unfortunately.
One day... One day...
I will get the bandana.
Well, I could also get the bandana.
What is it?
You'll get the bandana...
It's not... It's not getting big boss rank.
I think it's just...
Less than like 10 kills or something in the game.
Isn't it or something?
Is it no kills?
No kills.
Bandana is no kills.
I want the stealth.
I want the octocamo.
Well, we have octo.
You know, I want the...
Whatever.
I can't... I'm not remembering.
Let's just do this for now.
Actually, no.
I lied.
I do want the... I do want this instead.
I do want this one instead.
I have no chaff, so get rid of it.
I can't rely on chaffs, but I will maybe grab a stun grenade.
Maybe.
I don't think... Does playboy even work for the...
For the frogs?
Not that I've put down any at all anyway.
You know what?
We can do this instead.
Yuri?
If they're cool, yeah.
Alright, this is for...
This is for the...
Geckos.
This is for the people.
Alright.
I'm scared.
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh my gosh, they're right there.
They're right there.
Scary!
Okay, alright.
I know where to go.
I just am scared.
Oh my god, there's so many people.
There's so many people!
There's so many of them!
Yeah, just your imagination.
Exactly.
Where are you going?
Oh, she's jumping around.
Oh my god, please stop flying.
Okay.
Am I good?
No, I'm not good.
Wait,
did they see that?
No?
No one's there.
Onwards!
On...
Shit.
No!
Oh my god, I just stuck them up.
I didn't even mean to.
I was already on alert though, was I not?
Oh god!
Oh god, they actually see me.
Oh shit.
Can I barrel?
Can I... Will they see me if I barrel?
Do I have my barrel?
No, I don't have...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Um...
We don't need this.
Drum can!
Yeah, the alert never goes away.
Technically, I've been on alert this whole time.
Oh god.
It's really that guy that I have to worry about?
Did you just throw a grenade?
You bastard!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Can I... Can I... Wait.
Alright, let's...
Oh, jeez.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm getting... I'm getting a little...
I'm getting a little...
I'm getting a little flustered.
I hate this part.
Are you down?
There we go.
Oh my gosh.
Because we gotta destroy these...
Since...
What's on fire?
Oh my gosh.
No!
There we go.
This lady is still knocked out.
We're gonna do it again.
Actually, let me just put her to sleep.
Oops, let me reload.
And sleep.
Okay, good job, good job.
Alright.
Alright, there's gonna be...
A door over there.
We gotta get through.
Hold
on!
Oh my god, please.
Jeez, lady.
Holy...
Alright, I'm gonna have to go for it.
In a minute.
Oh god!
Let's go!
Oh god.
No, no, no!
This is the part I hate the most!
Save me!
Oh shit.
Please!
Everything is bad.
Everything is bad right now.
Everything is so bad.
I hate this part!
No!
Let me through, please!
I'm so dead.
I'm so dead!
I hate this part!
I'm also gonna grenade!
Nevermind!
Strategic...
Strategic fail!
I
hate this part!
I never know how to do this part!
Ever!
I never know!
Snake!
Oh
my god!
How did I...
How did I get auto...
I just suddenly have auto-aim on.
You bitch!
Please!
Oh, I have no bullets.
I'm gonna...
What's the point of even continuing?
I have one ration left.
I literally wasted all of them.
What's even the point of continuing onwards?
What's even the point?
What's the point?
I hate that part!
I'm almost half tempted to just kill myself and...
Start over.
I was fine until...
Until the...
Dang...
Stupid ass...
Stupid...
Metal gears...
Or not the metal gears...
The geckos...
I'm so angry!
I'm so...
I'm so mad!
I'm so angry!
Who's there?
How did you get there, Meryl?
I have a lot of stun grenades.
Maybe I do try cheesing it.
Oh boy, that's a lot of people!
That's a lot of people!
And...
Don't start shooting at me, please!
Okay, hold on...
I hate that it switches out my gun every time.
I hate it!
I wonder...
I don't remember if I killed them or not though.
Actually, what did I have there?
I don't even remember.
What if I just killed them all?
What's the point of doing...
Doing non-lethal anyway anymore?
What's the point?
No!
Anyway...
Ouch!
Come on!
I'm trying to...
Snake!
Oh my god!
You seriously, you stupid...
Stupid ass!
I can't with you right now.
Oh my god.
Ouch!
I think I really just want to die.
Is this what humans feel?
Is this how humans feel?
Is this it?
Do I finally understand?
Wishing for sweet death?
I'm a ghost, so I don't really understand.
I don't really get it, but...
Today I just really am...
Just ready to end it all, I think.
I think I'm just ready to end it all.
Sorry, I'm a bit going through it today, you guys.
There we go.
Wait, is there anybody left?
Oh, they're
upstairs.
Oh no!
I forgot to leave one!
Oh well, it's fine.
I got you though, right?
Oh my god, my aim.
Please.
My aim.
Come on, snake.
You got this.
I just keep hitting glass.
I think you're getting it.
I think you got her.
Probably.
Did you get her?
I can't tell.
That one, I think I saw bounce off, literally.
Stop, snake!
Stop seeing double!
Actually, this is kind of what my VR headset looked like yesterday.
I'm not gonna lie.
This is how I was viewing the entire stream yesterday.
Hello.
Why am I so bad at everything?
Where's the other ones?
Oh, they're coming down.
Hello.
I'm just gonna lay and get more...
Get more health.
I wanna restart.
I wanna restart the game.
I'm so weak.
I'm so bad.
Where did you come from?
She's right in front of you!
How could you crash?
I wanna restart.
I have no rations left.
Hold on, guys.
Sorry, I need a break.
I just started the stream!
I'm sorry!
I considered canceling stream today, I'll be honest.
But I didn't want to hold off Metal Gear.
Okay, I just gotta get over it.
Sorry, guys.
Sorry, sorry.
Yeah, Sunny for motivation.
The iPad or the iPod.
What is Sunny doing?
Is she cooking?
I can't tell.
Sunny, turn around!
Is she playing her PSP?
Is she?
It's so hard to tell.
I can't tell.
She looks stressed, too.
She's just like me, for real, for real.
It looks like her hands are on her head.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry, guys.
Okay, let's just do our best, I suppose.
If I die, I die.
I don't even know where they're at.
Oh, there's one.
There's one!
What the hell are you shooting from?
Oh god, we're gonna die.
Where did you go?
Where did you go from?
Actually, I think I will just die.
You know what?
Let's just die.
Let's just start over.
Kill me, please!
Kill me!
Let me start over.
Kill me.
Oh, okay.
Where does... How do you jump up like that?
Where do you go?
Just kill me.
There we go.
Okay.
But I think I'm in more danger.
I think before they get to me.
Otacon!
I'm the one in danger!
Can I even go through here?
Oh shit.
Oop, oop, oop.
What if I lay here?
Oop, oop.
I got you.
I turned around.
Damn it.
So close.
She was like, ah, no, I'm not gonna deal with that.
They're all like falling asleep around Meryl's body actually.
Oop, oop.
Nope, nope, nope.
Ouch!
I thought it was gonna be another stun, like the flashbang.
Where are they shooting at?
Friendly fire.
Oh, there's one.
Dang it.
Just missed her.
Ai, ai, ai.
Oh, wait, wait, where'd you go?
Stop moving so fast.
Where'd you go?
No, I really can't see you.
Oh, there you are, I think.
Is that you?
No, nobody's there.
Oh, oh wait, I think they already fell asleep.
Alright.
No, this isn't the Mantis fight quite yet.
Not yet.
Hello!
I need to
move out from my safety corner.
I thought more would come down to see me.
Mark...Wait.
No.
Marco!
Where are they even shooting at?
I think they think they see me.
But they're just a little silly.
I feel like I should move, but...
I also don't quite want to.
I got a good little spot here.
And you're telling me to get out of that?
Are they above me?
Oh, the Mark III.
Where are you?
Oh, wait there.
Go Mark III!
Neon!
Just kidding.
Bodies are heavy.
Bodies are big and heavy.
Where are they?
There's a guy there.
I think they're up here.
Oh yeah, they see.
They think they see me.
Or they probably do, they just can't get to me.
And they won't move anywhere.
So it's those two...three.
Oh wait!
I saw that person.
There they are.
Can you like move a little bit over here?
Just a tiny bit.
Like right exactly here.
Are they even gonna come back?
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna try and get rid of that glass.
There they are.
And now...
Yeah, triangles first.
Got them?
Thank you!
Now you leave.
Now you jump down, huh?
Wait, what if I...
Come here.
Come here!
I go!
I got him.
I got myself too.
Flashbang rail.
Snake, you're kinda going through it, but that's okay buddy.
We can power through without our meds.
That's right.
The pile of bodies grows.
I saw, but somebody just jumped down.
As long as they come over here and don't...
Oh, I was gonna say don't jump.
Shit.
The pile of bodies grows.
Frog pile.
Not everyone is coming and seeing the frog pile.
And they're like...
I don't think that's safe.
That doesn't seem pretty good.
That doesn't seem...
Nope.
This doesn't seem...
This doesn't seem very good over here, does it?
No!
Some of them are too fast for me.
This is the best spawn...
No.
No, no, no!
That was so close.
What if they ended up throwing the grenade, but it like... right there.
Oh!
Yay!
We did it!
Where did all the bodies go?
Meryl is like just completely covered in frogs.
The frog pile huggers.
That's a lot of bodies.
And they were just like... some of them would come over and just like turn around.
It's so funny.
Where have I seen this before?
Snake?
Run!
Oh gosh.
Asaka!
No!
It can't be!
The fishing wire is so lame though.
I'll be honest.
You wish you were him.
You wish you were him!
Oh my gosh, our savior.
Johnny!
My man ate those heads.
Screaming Mantis.
I just realized...
That's why it's called the sorrow doll.
It's based off the sorrow.
Oh my god.
I just realized it looks like the sorrow.
So that's the Mantis one.
That's all we have.
I just realized it.
I never noticed what they look like.
Oh Johnny!
He's taking psychic damage.
See?
You can see it.
I don't remember how to do this fight at all.
How could you not notice until now?
I don't know.
I'm just not observing I guess.
Couples activity idea?
Which part?
Do I need the camera?
I guess not.
Oh wait.
Just kidding.
The doll is under here.
Mantis doll.
Let's see what it does.
I only have the Mantis doll.
That's why I never took a good look at the sorrow doll.
I don't have the sorrow doll.
I just never looked at him.
I just didn't look.
I just realized why the mint plush is called mint plush.
I just thought that it was just like...
Sad doll.
But that also explains what happens after this fight too.
I have so much more context now.
Look at this guy.
What a gamer posture.
His head is even too heavy for his neck.
Who designed this?
Skinny legend.
Creator and age unknown.
I think they are just embarrassed.
Has the ability to release ghosts!
If a ghost hits a person with active nanomachines, it will allow you to manipulate their body.
Let's try it out.
In what way?
I guess we'll see.
Ready with L1.
Release ghost with R1.
Releasing ghost!
Release ghost!
Release!
Oh god dammit.
Why did you do this to me?
Ouch!
Release!
I'm really bad at this.
Oh my god.
Release!
Nenees!
I'm so bad at this.
Release!
How is everyone?
I know they are ducking and dodging.
I just think it's funny.
Release!
Oh my gosh, my own.
Don't control me!
Nenees!
Oh my gosh, ouch.
Where is he anyway?
Uh-oh.
What's that sound?
Isn't there something with cutting the wires or the strings too?
Gosh, I can't remember.
The globe?
Oh there he is!
Nenees!
Oh gosh, I got to get rid of the wires somehow.
Do I have to syringe?
Come here Meryl.
Come
here!
Come here!
I can't even be angry.
Oh my gosh, how do you use it on yourself again?
I can't remember how to do it.
X?
You guys, it's not X.
Use it in menu.
Oh, that's right.
I never use it.
Thank you!
Nenees!
Does this do anything?
Oh, I'm really taking bullets again.
Nenees!
Maybe to him.
Oh geez.
Oh shit, it didn't do anything.
Oh Mantis, why you gotta have such special...
How much special things about you, huh?
Hold on, I gotta gain some more health.
Oh, oh yay!
Alright, turn around snake.
Turn around, there we go.
Nice.
And let's see if we can get anybody from here.
I gotta get the sorrow one though.
Oh god!
What the hell is that?
Oh shit.
Hey, can you guys chill for a second?
Chill for like two seconds, please.
I don't know how to do this damn fight.
Oh my gosh, so scary.
I need your doll, please!
Oh, I'm out of bullets.
Not good.
I got another ration though, that's good.
Ok.
Did it drop?
It didn't seem to drop.
I mean, did it drop it?
Oh no!
Oh no, it's so familiar!
Familiar!
Oh my god.
Drop it!
Drop your doll!
My doll!
Ouch!
Oh jeez.
Ok, I gotta do my thingy again.
It's hanging on by literal threads.
Sorry.
Where is she?
Oh my god.
Oops.
Good thing everybody has bad aim.
Good thing they all have bad aim.
Oh my goodness.
Drop your sorrow doll, please.
Please!
I need it.
Ouch.
I need it actually.
Can I have your doll?
Just one more hit.
You bastard.
I got that guy.
Oh I'm out of bullets!
I need to buy more.
I need to buy more bullets.
Ok.
Alright.
We're doing alright guys.
We're doing ok.
We're doing alright.
Just normal bullets.
What a time to be out of ammo, right?
It's only 600 dp.
More bullets!
Damn it.
I forgot that I needed to reload.
Take that.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Can you get out of my way?
These guys are pain in my side.
Are you throwing people at me now?
Dang it!
You made me lose my shot!
I thought for a second.
Dang it.
Oh shit.
Ow, ow, ow.
Oh, ouch.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Please.
Oh, I need to reload.
Oh my god.
I'm too slow.
Yes!
Oh my god.
I got it.
I got it!
I'm gonna get your other one too.
I'm gonna steal both of them.
I'm gonna take them all.
You'll have nothing left.
I'm gonna rob you blind!
I'm gonna rob you!
Rob
you, screaming mantis.
You will have nothing left to your name.
Nothing mantis about you.
Please!
Get the other.
Oh, hi Meryl.
Ouch.
I'm gonna try and get some of these guys down too.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh, even that, even...
Oops, why did I do that?
Oh my
gosh!
Can I add the... I wonder if it does anything now.
I know the dolls are supposed to do damage, but I don't know if it's after you...
Okay, now?
I wonder.
Okay, there we go.
It's not taking any damage though.
Oh, I hate these things.
I hate these things!
Oh my gosh!
I got a mantis her.
It's the doll, mantis doll?
Okay.
Why am I so bad?
It's okay to backseat because I don't remember how to do this fight.
Ha!
A rag doll.
And we got both dolls!
Yippee!
We shook her.
We shook her good.
Where is her statue?
That don't seem so good.
Yeah, time to see her beautified form.
No!
All her little eggies!
Oh gosh, snake!
Maybe you have any sort of survival instinct there.
All her grey hairs.
Oh yeah!
They do look like dwarf gecko arms, right?
They could very well be.
Statue should be where you camped against the frogs.
Oh, no kidding!
That's so funny.
Thank you.
Thanks for helping me guys against the fight.
Thank you, thank you.
There's always something silly with these fights, right?
With the mantis.
It's the mantis style.
Yeah, we did it!
Mmhm.
And that's the last babe.
That's the last beauty babe too.
My vision.
Oh my goodness.
I can't help it, they're just in my face!
I can't help it!
They're right there!
The screams.
Me too.
Make them stop!
I don't want to hear them anymore!
She hit the invisible wall.
The edge of the world.
Is she a mime?
Nah.
Get out of my body.
Forgive me.
Ahem.
One moment ma'am.
Where did I camp out over here?
There's a pretty little statue right here that I need to grab.
Yeah!
That's the last one!
Oh, wait.
I'm stuck in here?
Ok, just kidding.
Explosion!
She's really slow.
Sometimes they're very fast, right?
But she's very slow.
Let's get our twin barrel.
For later.
Hello ma'am!
Look at her walking around.
Thanks for the superchats you guys!
I'll read them in a second.
Nothing here.
Hello ma'am.
I'm running.
Does it work on her?
I wonder.
I don't know actually.
Doesn't seem like it.
She dodges it.
I think it's too slow for this, you know?
I think it's kinda slow.
She's gonna try and grab you.
She's gonna try and grab me.
Where's my camera?
Oh yeah lady.
Oh yeah.
Give me a good smile.
Watch out!
What are we doing?
I'll show you.
We're waiting.
That's what we're doing.
Hello ma'am.
Why don't you put your arms out and try to give me a hug, huh?
Where's my hug?
There it is!
She's...
Where's my hug?
Discord mod looking ass.
Get out of here!
We just gotta wait a couple of minutes guys.
Don't worry.
Run, run, run!
Are you gonna... What if we listen to our favorite song?
Screams are so overrated.
We're not listening to Screamo here.
We're listening to Oishii Touhan Seikatsu!
It's the screaming.
It's just so funny.
Let's see if we can break all the glass in this place.
Okay.
All the glass I think.
We did it ma'am.
Just kidding, there's more.
Down here too.
Just kidding.
It's too early.
Hurry up!
She's so slow.
So slow.
The timing!
Holy moly.
Give me a smile honey.
Okay, nevermind.
She looks like the Joker over here.
Looks like the Jo... Oh, I need more bullets.
Let's see.
Motion mag.
I really don't need that much.
Maybe like...
One...
More bullets.
No more cries.
Smile only.
Oh yeah.
Cheese!
That was close.
What about a dance?
Give me a little dance honey.
Oh, we forgot to put our song on.
Dance for me!
Oh, there she goes.
Let's see if we can get another silly photo.
That's not quite...
Oh gosh.
She really looks like the Joker a bit, huh?
Oh man.
Is that your blood down there?
Oh no, those are my casings.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Give me a smile.
That's how you play the game you guys.
Haunted house sound effect.
Return to baby.
Little fetus.
My controller is vibrating.
It's actually Psycho fetus!
Yes.
What do you know about me?
What if I...
What if I did find a way to play this on a Playstation?
Even a PS2.
Oh, putting my controller.
I'll put it on my phone so you can hear it.
Okay, it's on my phone.
Yes.
Oh it's really light.
I don't think you can hear it.
It's moving!
Vibration is back baby!
Ripperoni.
Sorrow!
The sorrow saved us!
Yes.
Oh yeah.
And that's why I was just like, oh it makes sense that he had the sorrow doll.
I love how Mantis showed up just to show off again.
I know.
Was it a missed opportunity that Meryl wasn't the last BMV?
But then, if you don't beat her non-lethally, it kind of ruins the point.
You wouldn't want to kill Meryl.
It would make sense if the Otacon ending was canon.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
It was deck.
That's how you get dysentery.
And the dysentery.
Yeah.
It went to...
The trickster is born.
Bum bum.
That's why she's...
That's why she's discount Psycho Mantis.
Having to use strings.
She wasn't screaming that much.
I think I was screaming more than her.
I think I was screaming more than she was.
We're fine.
Yeah, bye Droven.
Alright guys.
That was...
That was the last BMV.
I'm a secret member of BMV.
Oh Meryl.
Meryl, you good?
Where did everybody else go?
I don't care about the frogs.
Oh that's right.
Johnny was here too.
Great question.
Oh yeah.
Johnny got shot like 5 times.
Don't say who.
I love Johnny.
I like Johnny.
Oh no Meryl.
You're not gonna be able to get the banana.
Banana.
The bandana.
I love this part.
Everyone's just like, Snake it's our turn.
It's our turn Snake.
You've done so much for us.
I love it.
I love this part.
Let him cook.
Screaming Mindo.
Whatever that means.
On the other side of the hallway or on the other side in the afterlife.
Oh Meryl.
I think you're outnumbered.
And out bulleted.
Other side of the mission.
Alright, so here...
Welcome to where we would have farmed.
Welcome to the farming zone.
Welcome!
No way.
Yes way!
I love this part though.
Why don't we get somebody else?
Infinite respawning.
That's what I'm saying!
To be fair, Meryl dragged herself into this because...
Go!
It makes you so lag.
Oh gosh.
That whole...
That whole scene.
Oh gosh, Meryl!
Okay, we just, we just, we just left.
Okay, Meryl.
It's okay.
You're okay.
No.
Meryl, no!
CQC!
Why didn't we teach her CQC?
Why didn't we teach her...
Zombieman, welcome to membership.
He made it!
Look at that gun.
Holy moly.
Maybe run.
Somehow.
Kept you waiting, huh?
I don't think it was clear.
The dream team!
Who needs aim anyway?
This guy!
Okay, that's so valid though.
That's so valid.
I would maybe do the same.
He saved your life because he wasn't...
Maybe...
You could have, you could have, you could have thrown them at her, you know?
They were warranted.
Yeah.
Oh yeah!
Let's watch him shit his pants again!
With his ass out!
And he saw her ass too!
The Mr. and Mrs. Smith moment.
Real.
Look at his face!
He's loading a gun for her!
Yeah, actually.
He's the bottom in this relationship.
Sure.
Oh, that's a grenade.
How
do they have so many people?
I love blooms on the battlefield.
Oh my gosh, we're bleeding on top of each other.
Don't even think about cheating on me.
All the frogs, like, kinda looking at each other like...
Are we interrupting?
You guys are like seven wheeling right now.
Give her a real wedding, Johnny!
It's been my dream since I was a little girl.
And then she had the psychotherapy.
Whatever happened to that?
Johnny better be thanking Snake with his entire being.
That Snake broke the hypnotherapy.
Her dream was to be a soldier.
Clearly it wasn't.
No,
they can pass!
Hold on, this is so awkward.
Wait, excuse me.
So this is where we would have, like, you know...
Farms and everything?
Holy moly, my ears.
Hold on, sorry, there we go.
This is where we would have farmed and gotten lots and lots...
And lots and lots of money.
Let's just sit in here.
Lots and lots of money.
Getting lots and lots of money.
Thank goodness we have the Patriot with unlimited ammo!
Get that one right there.
There we go.
But alas, today...
Let's see, how much do we got?
I'm already at 54!
I mean, but I got some of that from earlier too.
I think it would have taken a long time.
Always can drop a save for future Minto to farm.
Yeah, I feel I should, right?
Because that's why I tried to do it before...
And I didn't have a save.
I didn't have a save, so I couldn't come back here so easily.
I would have had to...
Who's shooting me?
I'm so tempted to just be like...
You know, it's so tempting.
You don't get a lot though.
You only get 50 DP from these guys.
But I mean, that adds up if you do a ton of them.
At this point, we don't even need anything.
We don't need the stealth camo.
We don't need anything, you know?
At this point, it's basically all over.
We're just sitting here.
Okay, let's see how much we get in like one minute.
And then we can do the math.
Somebody do a minute from right here.
It's almost relaxing.
I literally am just holding down.
Time start.
I was at 52.
These are the things that were on the Lady and Raiden's game.
They are, yes!
It's the same thing.
Yeah, who needs cookie clicker?
So true.
This is the boss's will.
Yeah, these are the little dwarf geckos that are...
That are referenced in Rising, yeah.
Do you guys like Patriot ASMR?
Oh, it's probably been a minute, right?
Oh shoot.
What are we at?
55.
We're at 55.
So...
It's better than I was expecting.
I think it would be...
It might take like...
Yeah, like 10k a minute.
No, a little more.
No, not 10k.
Because we were at 52.
Now we're at 55.
It would take a little bit of time.
It would take a little bit of time, huh?
Yeah, just a little bit.
Oh, I was at 54?
Oh, just kidding.
Alright, let's keep going.
Wait for me!
We're rolling, rolling.
Like we're Katamari Damashii.
Katamari Damashii.
Oh, I'm not even running anymore.
There we go.
Yay!
Okay.
Oh, snake.
I don't think he's doing so hot, you guys.
Snake, you're okay, buddy?
Snake...
Oh my god, why are there gonna be froggies here?
Snake!
She's like, hold.
We don't even have to do anything to this guy.
He's so pathetic.
Knife fight.
This is so messed up.
Oh my god, snake is at his lowest of low.
It's so bad.
Oh my god.
Raiden!
He's got no arms.
Where
is that power in rising?
Where is the power to electrify people with my brain?
Everyone's coming.
Everyone's here.
Everyone's coming together.
My sword is a tool of justice.
How are you doing that?
Oh my god.
Excuse me?
No.
Don't steal my glory.
You're a robot, Raiden.
You won't make it.
Oh my god.
You have a baby!
You have a kid!
You
still have your youth.
Don't waste it.
You can start over.
From here on, this is my fight.
We tore the world apart.
Made your life a living hell.
How is that a spoiler?
She was literally pregnant at the end of 2, you guys.
It's my duty to put an end to all of this.
Alright.
I'll make sure they don't get through.
Kind of the frogs to let them act out a ton of violence.
Hold on until we insert the virus.
I like how Otacon is just like...
Yeah, the frogs are just chilling.
They could have done...actually they did the same for Meryl and Johnny.
Just let them talk it out.
Oh my gosh.
Where did these all...where did they come from?
I guess that means that Meryl and Johnny failed.
Thank you...snake.
It's my fault because I didn't kill any of them but they all woke up.
Yeah, I didn't kill any of the frogs so they're all waking up and coming here.
I think you need that, right?
To like fight.
It's me when I pick stuff off the ground with my feet.
It's like he's meditating.
They're so patient.
Why did they throw away their guns?
Oh gosh.
No, I don't want it to happen!
Come
on snake!
Oh snake!
Come on snake!
Oh god, his health going down.
I'm mashing!
Just one more hallway.
Just one more hallway please!
Everyone is doing their best.
I'm going!
I'm mashing!
Oh my god Rose, jump scare.
You're almost there.
You're almost there snake!
Oh my god!
Sunny!
She cooked them perfectly.
Look at her dancing.
Do it for Sunny!
I'm smashing!
Imagine it opens up and there's more.
Okay,
he's done burning on that side.
You have to flip him over so that he can burn on the other side.
You can't let him get too burnt on one side.
He's like the eggs now.
This is GW.
It's like a graveyard in here.
Not those flowers.
Leave it to me.
Petals of white.
Honestly, I actually don't understand why snake had to be here.
I don't quite understand it.
Why couldn't Otacon just take the MK3 and go?
The sensors?
Maybe that's it.
MK3 couldn't reach the door, no?
Oh my god.
That's not good.
I guess for this purpose, huh?
Gotta protect it.
Snake, turn your aimbot on!
That was so fast.
Raiden!
He instantly folded.
Oh my gosh.
Scooch faster!
Why'd you drop it?
Oh my god.
They were scared of you for two seconds and then you dropped it.
No!
It's so sad.
Oh my god.
Snake,
shoot!
Just shoot!
Oh my god.
No!
Imagine if they had me play this part.
And it kicks in...
No!
Oh, there it is.
We did it!
What?
Take her down.
Oh my gosh.
The sounds are so...
Poor baby.
She's such a baby.
Imagine.
Oh my gosh.
It's such a Jurassic Park moment.
It's so scary.
That's so scary.
Imagine.
You look out the window and see Ray screaming at you.
Oh there it is.
Oh my gosh.
Hi Raiders!
If you never played Metal Gear...
These are like crazy.
We are at the last part of the last game.
So these are like crazy, crazy spoilers.
War Cry!
Thank you for the Ray!
Oh my gosh.
But also if you intend on playing these games...
Thank you!
War Cry!
Oh boy.
Sorry, I'm about to get angry.
Never played?
Oh my gosh.
It's too emotional.
Oh, she's got a plaster of her face everywhere.
I'm so glad I could see you sing Snake Eater.
I'm so happy.
I was the loudest one in that room.
Oh my god.
I hope you're listening.
Doesn't even address Otacon.
The virus you uploaded is using GW as a conduit to annihilate the entire AI network.
It's set to destroy all four AIs along with JD, the core that tied them all together.
I've set this video to play back once they're all gone.
Oh my god.
Naomi.mp4
A little.
Okay.
This child prodigy.
Look at her.
She's so worried.
Sweet baby.
Fox is alive.
That means Sunny is the anti-Naomi.
Truly the bestest character ever.
The best character.
Sunny.
The music.
Don't cry for her.
Yeah, you should be.
You should be.
You?
You had everything.
You had many chances, Naomi.
And yet...
In the end...
You helped me feel the joy of living.
Thank you, Hal.
Thank you.
Hal.
The way she says his name there!
Look at her.
Look at how she's dramatically looking into the sea.
She's wiping away her tears like, I'm the main character.
I'm doing all this.
Oh my gosh, it's me.
Everybody's gonna love me.
Rising.
Now, she can build a new destiny for herself.
Snake.
The time has come.
You've earned your rest.
Snake.
The rose petal is about to fall.
Snake?
Snake!
Fringe killed him.
Naomi does that to me too.
If I weren't already dead, Naomi would've killed me a hundred times over.
Here it is, everybody.
Not a con!
Where did he go?
Like, where are you getting this medic?
Gotta equip pneumonia whenever Naomi speaks.
That's how I react to Naomi.
Fucking two!
Oh, golly gee.
I hope you guys didn't forget about the best character in the whole game!
Oh my, how did he get him up there?
So many mysteries.
You could've stopped us.
I stopped you.
Why would I want to do that?
This is just as I'd hoped things would end.
Back before father's time.
Before Zero gave birth to the Patriots.
The US, China and the Soviet Union formed a secret pact.
All according to plan.
The organization they created was called the Philosophers.
Through two world wars it spread its roots and extended its reach.
After that the Philosophers splintered and factions began to squabble over the fortune in the past.
They called it the Philosophers Legacy.
A massive cash of funds that would later provide the foundation for Zero's Patriots.
Zero sought to use his riches to achieve world domination.
Our father, Big Boss, sought to free himself from that chokehold.
His dream was to create an army of free citizens.
One that answered to no government.
Outer Heaven.
But he failed because of you.
Nine years ago I tried to free us from the control of machines.
Four years later our dear brother...
Was that... was that liquid from Twin Snakes?
All of that, all of it, was nothing more than a process of trial and error.
The end result of which is Outer Heaven.
To be free from funds of the Patriots.
The ultimate form of external control imposed on the Patriots soldiers.
The memes control us now.
The end result of which is Outer Heaven.
Free from FOXDIE.
Free from the system.
Free from ID control.
Snake is so done.
Our minds free from their prisons.
That is the haven I've yearned for.
In his lap.
One more.
Got his neck.
You'll have a score to settle.
Yes we do.
Oh my god.
Show me what you've got, Snake!
Oh my gosh, the arm.
The arm of liquid.
We're coming up on peak.
It's already peak, but oh gosh.
Oh my god, oh my god.
He's ruthless.
His nose.
Everything is broken.
Again.
I like how Liquid also wears an office name badge.
He's like, no, give me that.
No, give me that.
Don't share needles, kids.
Don't do that.
Liquid!
Oh my god.
Good.
Not by the bandana.
Not by the bandana, that's
so...
Brothers.
Coming in pretty geared up for that.
Oh
my god.
Oh my gosh.
The
life bars!
Nice
of him to let me...
Ouchie, ouchie.
Stop it.
Stop.
Give
me that.
Ouch,
I'll jump stuff.
Ouchie, ouch.
Snake.
Right behind you.
You are literally in front of me.
Next part.
Ouchie, ouch.
One of the greatest battles in gaming history, you guys!
Oh my gosh.
Get up, Snake.
Oh god, I took a...
I should have dodged that.
Good job, Snake.
Good job, good job.
Don't worry, I'm ready for...
The next part.
But I'm not ready.
I'm not ready.
Oh god.
I can't...
Wait, how do I get him close to me?
There we go.
What?
Snake.
Oh shit.
Oh god, I'm gonna die here.
I can't concentrate at all.
No!
Ouch!
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Yeah.
No!
Oops,
I missed it.
Ouch!
Ouch.
I missed it.
Not over yet.
No.
Remember who you are.
The last beauty.
It's true.
No.
I can't.
It's too good.
It's too good every time.
It's true though.
No.
Traumatic spin.
He's so stupid.
You didn't have to be on your back.
This guy.
No.
So dramatic.
What took you so long?
Was the medic on the toilet or something?
Yeah,
he didn't want to interrupt Peek.
No.
That's me right?
I need that.
I need that kind of comfort.
Sunny.
No.
God, Snake goes through the most in this damn act.
I wonder if we did the right thing.
Naomi.
No, don't think of her.
What did we lose?
You lost your virginity.
Sorry.
No, sorry.
Not now Otacon.
Okay, we are about to go into movie mode.
Sorry.
Oh, jeez.
I'm okay.
We are about to go into movie mode.
That was it.
That was it of the gameplay everybody.
Isn't that crazy?
Let's save the game.
I'm going to go party real quick.
We'll save and then we shall... So, give me, like, maybe...
Wait, is it going to... Wait, do I need to pause?
Hold on.
Uh-oh.
Wait a second.
Wait!
Oh no!
Wait.
Wait!
Okay.
Alright.
Everybody, party break.
Party break because we got more to go through.
And there is more.
There is more.
Break time.
Get your popcorn.
Get your drinks.
I'm okay.
I'm not okay, but I'm okay.
No!
Okay.
No, BRB.
I'm back.
No, I'm back.
For those... Do you guys understand why I love Ocelot so much?
Do you guys understand why I love Ocelot so much?
That man...
That man basically... He got made fun of and it changed his brain chemistry.
He was like... He was like...
He got... He got infantilized once and then was just like...
You know what?
Then I'm going to...
You made fun of me.
I'm going to make the whole world suffer.
The pure...
The pure love of the game.
The pure love of Big Boss.
He was like... I'm going to do all this.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
I'm not ready.
Okay.
Let's go.
Remind me later.
Epilogue time.
Remind me later and I'll sing you happy birthday.
Oh my god.
She's a bride!
Oh my
god.
Campbell jumpscare.
I don't like that hair on her though.
The hair stuff.
I guess back then hair bumps were kind of in, right?
When this game was made.
Hair is kind of goofy.
She looks like a princess.
Damn.
I even hold it up if you're not going to go through with it.
Yeah, do what you want.
Totally called her bluff.
You've got a chance to win me over.
I'm mad with a dad.
Well,
you're pretty old.
I wouldn't say plenty.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
She's so cute.
Meryl.
You look beautiful.
Look at the highlighter she uses.
All over her body.
I'm hiding her beefy arms.
Sorry.
No!
Happy wedding day.
Okay.
Yeah, get a dress that shows off your arms.
Why Johnny fell in love with you?
Oh my god, why would you give him a white tux?
This man, you would give him something white to wear?
No.
Absolutely not.
A little sentence.
Eating popcorn at the wedding.
I'm missing somebody.
Pray.
Or clean bowel movements.
A new team on their first mission.
We're giggling.
He's like what the hell?
Oh my god Trevon.
That's who we were missing.
A
shower of flowers.
Compliments of Drebin.
A little something extra for me.
Sunny C meeting another human being for the first time.
Why is this kid here anyway?
Why?
Sunny meeting a person her age for the first time actually.
Oh my god.
The monkey has a nicotine addiction, caffeine addiction and is an alcoholic.
Sunny!
That's me too.
Me too Sunny.
The bouquet.
Let Mayling get the bouquet!
Where
is Snake?
Come
on Snake.
Guy always keeps you waiting.
She
was a bride just like she wanted.
Just like she wanted.
Who could this be?
Oh boy.
He's in his...oh I thought he was in his undies.
Thank goodness.
Mr. Raiden.
You have a visitor.
Poor.
What is...the thing is beeping but it's not hooked up to him at all actually.
I just realized.
Virgil.
It really is.
It does look just like Virgil.
Oh my god.
He's a little baby Virgil.
Is it wifi?
Oh ok.
Because he's a robot.
He's like what is that thing.
Raiden!
This is so classic.
This is so classic Raiden and Rose.
Oh my god.
Raiden.
I miss these days.
Look at the boy.
Use your special eyes.
Not the kid in the mirror.
He's like why am I here?
What's going on?
No.
Really?
You think that kid looks like Campbell?
So immediate.
So fast.
Oh yeah she did say that didn't she?
Oh my god.
She did say that.
Yeah you lied.
I also lied about that.
Caused you a lot of trauma.
Oh my god.
Rose.
Girl you're the best to ever do it.
Oh my god.
Rose is the definition of gaslight, gatekeep, girlboss.
But you're too unstable Raiden.
I'm sorry.
This kid, he's here.
Speak.
John.
Hello.
My name's Virgil.
My son.
Sorry.
Oh my god.
It's like Frankenstein moving at him.
I would be too.
Oh my god he's got such glistening eyes.
He's got his father's eyelashes.
Little John.
John Raiden.
I think you're cool.
Kinda like a comic book superhero.
Okay little John.
That's enough talking.
I'm not scared.
You're like a comic book superhero.
My son.
I'll never abandon you.
Until rising.
I'm done running.
For now.
I love this part of the ending so much.
This kid is so awkward.
He literally says two things.
And then just stares.
Stares.
I'm done lying.
Oh just kidding.
She's not.
I'm done lying to you.
And that was a lie.
Oh papa.
Papa!
Oh papa!
Oh happy family.
She's never done lying.
Oh gosh I love this goofy terrible family.
I love this horrible dynamic.
You guys have filled me with so much.
So much entertainment.
Look at them.
I didn't say that.
I wasn't talking about me.
Go Rose!
And I'm the beauty.
What an egotistical woman.
At that very moment he was just thinking.
He was like.
I was right thinking that.
I wasn't talking about you being the beauty.
I was so right to think of you as an egotistical woman.
He's just staring at her like.
Where the hell did you get that idea from?
Oh gosh I love them.
Okay back to tears.
Okay serious.
Back to serious.
Okay all serious from here on out.
All serious.
Serious.
It's the title screen.
Who left the flowers?
A hero forever loyal to the flames of war.
Snake.
He finally got his cigarette.
You've endured so much Snake.
Sorry.
No!
Not the meme.
Serious.
Snake no no no no.
No Snake!
I hate this part.
Seriously?
Thank you so much.
You guys that was sent.
That was
sent 30 minutes ago.
We are like insane.
No no.
Oh my god.
My stomach hurts.
I think it got delayed because of a bunch of...
Because of a bunch of gifted donors.
Or gifted memberships.
And so it got delayed for 30 minutes.
Thank you so much though.
Holy moly.
I wish I was the one who kissed Snake or the one who got kissed by Ocelot.
Same.
Same to both of that.
Oh my gosh.
The timing was insane.
All according to plan.
No.
Lambda are you still here?
Holy moly.
Okay.
Let's keep going.
You are...
Serious.
Back to serious.
Also thank you Andregos.
Thank you guys for all the donors as well.
Sorry I couldn't say everything.
Say thank you all.
Everything was happening.
CrunchyPBJ, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Senor Caruso, thank you so much for another 50 gifted.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm going to be playing Peace Walker in 5.
Alright, alright.
Serious.
Snake just went through it you guys.
Okay.
Why do you act like you know him so well Otacon?
Oh.
That makes sense.
No need to hold back anymore, huh?
Oh,
SOP syndrome.
SOP kept more than just alcohol under control.
Those poor slobs are virtually naked now.
Now they have to...
They have to learn how to deal with their emotions.
Oh no!
I guess getting rid of the Patriots won't solve all our problems overnight.
You probably already suspected this but...
I'm not actually an employee of AT security.
Huh?
Time for Drebbin's sad backstory.
The dang Patriots.
Yep.
Who...
Who isn't it's former child soldier in this game?
Where's the other Drebbins?
What are they doing?
Because they let me.
Sonny is the current child soldier.
Wow.
You mean the entity that was so good at controlling everything...
Was actually controlling everything?
No, it's an anagram for PATRIOT!
Hey, hey.
That's not your line.
Almost.
Do you have a job now?
Easy there.
But if the guns...
But if the guns don't have the locks on them...
Do they still need to be laundered?
And isn't the war supposed to be over?
Aren't wars supposed to be over?
They still sell guns?
But couldn't they buy guns from anyone?
Whatever.
It's fine.
War never changes.
Until it does.
He's like, that's my wife!
Oh yeah!
Oh yeah.
What's this dude yapping about?
Get that bottle out of this man's hand.
It's Rebin's first time being drunk.
Yeah.
No, Sunny.
Give it to him!
He's my very first outside friend.
So cute.
You don't want to be a hikikomori anymore like me?
Don't guilt her, Otacon.
She can still go outside and live with you.
It's not one or the other.
Look, she's a free bird.
The sun looks so pretty.
I like it outside.
Aww.
He's so sad.
He's like...
No.
I hate this life.
No!
I wonder if I'll ever see him again.
Are you crying, Uncle Hal?
No.
I'm not crying.
I'm crying.
No.
This is what happens when she only eats eggs instead of ramen noodles her entire life up until now.
The part when Otacon gets sad at Sunny because she wants to be outside.
He turns around and he's just like...
I'm so disappointed in her.
She's a normie.
After I tried to write Voice of God.
Big Boss?
He didn't talk in this game.
He didn't do it.
That's right.
Good.
No need for you to go just yet.
It's been a long time, Snake.
No.
Big Boss?
But you...
You were liquid.
Not liquid, but you were soup.
You were in the body bag.
How?
He's got the Patriot.
Why were you soup?
And how are you here?
And you still have a grudge against him.
Uh oh.
Going for the CQC.
The CQC hug!
That's weird.
Time for you to put aside the gun and live.
Yeah, deconstruct that stuff.
Yeah.
It all began with a bunch of old fools.
They've all passed away.
Their era of folly is over.
I'm the only one left.
And soon, I'll be gone too.
How can you still be alive?
That body, liquid burned on the Volta, wasn't mine.
That was the body of a clone.
What other clone was there?
Solidus!
My man, Solidus.
No way!
Poor Solidus.
Eva died for Solidus.
So he's been asleep this whole time?
Thank you for the superchat.
Zero.
Oh, stop.
Stop.
That's why Solidus was soup.
He had no skin.
No.
This...
This freak is weird.
This guy...
Someone can be made to play a specific role.
I love cats.
The way he talks about us.
Oh my god.
Zero jump scare.
Holy hell.
Oh god.
Potato man.
I just accidentally poured all my popcorn all over the floor.
Oops.
Oopsie.
Actually, most of it's in my lap.
Not the AI marketer.
What?
I'm so confused.
Holy moly, this is real Metal Gear Solid.
Yeah.
This is probably some of the craziest lore dump in the game.
Without change.
That's not good.
The war economy.
The AI was just like, how can we make more money?
War.
This is so messed up, because it's like Zero's will.
Exactly, it was supposed to be the boss's will.
And it got so screwed.
The fact that they would interpret Zero's will as wanting more war when the boss was just like no.
She sacrificed herself to not have war.
They just screwed it all up.
It's so wacky, it's so screwy.
She literally sacrificed herself so that America and Russia would not go to war.
Like, it's so...everything is just...the worst miscommunication case ever.
There was only the war economy.
It was a colossal error in judgment.
One Zero couldn't possibly have foreseen.
If you...I mean you couldn't foresee it.
He just...oh my god.
Wow, that guy still has hair.
I never realized.
I thought he was just a bald potato.
He's completely unaware of the fact that he led the world to the brink of ruin.
If you think it's pathetic seeing Snake the way he is in this game...
It's really pathetic seeing Zero like this.
Nah, he's just a pathetic old man.
He's like 200 years old.
He could become that guy from Warhammer.
Did you miss the piss jokes?
One more!
Woo!
The Emperor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All of them.
Everybody is gone.
In chaos.
The world is born from Zero.
The moment Zero becomes One is the moment the world springs to life.
One becomes Two.
Two becomes Ten.
Ten becomes 100.
What's this math?
What math is he mathing?
Taking it all back to One solves nothing.
So long as Zero remains, One will eventually grow to 100 again.
And so, our goal was to erase Zero.
Even the mighty Patriots began with a single man.
That one man's desires grew huge, bloated.
Absorbed technology began to manipulate the economy.
We realized too late that we had created a beast.
We had helped turn Zero.
His sin was ours.
But for that reason, I'm taking it upon myself to send Zero back to nothing.
Unplug him.
Do it.
That was so fast.
Goodbye,
Major Zero.
You going back to Zero as well?
You erased me two times before.
Today will mark the third.
The Fox die.
Zero planted in you.
It's already begun, eating away at my body.
Truth is, the Fox dying in you is what killed Eva.
Ocelot, what are you talking about?
Hail me.
She told me everything.
What's wrong?
They did it again.
They used you to kill me.
The Patriots know their proxies.
In order to bury us.
They did it again.
In the end, they're no more than a program.
All they can do is repeat the same pattern over and over again.
Do me a favor, will you?
Take me over to her.
When did she have the chance to talk to me?
I hate this.
There's one more thing Naomi wanted me to tell you.
Old Fox die in your body.
The one that mutated.
The new Fox die inside you continues to multiply.
At the same time, it is preventing the old mutated Fox die from reproducing.
The new Fox die is uprooting the old.
Naomi confirmed it in her follow up.
The mutants are receding.
Oh, see?
She couldn't tell you that directly.
Because, you know, you almost shot yourself.
The worst character to ever exist.
Even then, the process will just repeat itself.
One day, the new Fox die too will start to mutate.
And become a new threat.
But that is, if you manage to live that long.
It will probably be good for you.
I've never thought of you as a son.
But I've always respected you as a soldier.
As a man.
If you'd been in my place back then.
Maybe you wouldn't have made the same mistakes that I did.
Ever since the day I killed the Boss.
I was already dead.
No, that is why he's Big Boss.
It's not about changing the world.
It's about doing our best to live the way it is.
It's about respecting the will of others.
Believing in your own.
Isn't that what you thought?
At last, I understand the meaning behind what you did.
At last, I understand the truth behind your courage.
You can do it!
It's almost time for me to go.
And with me, the last ember of this fruitless war dies out.
And at last, those old evils will be gone.
Once the source of evil returns to zero, a new one, a new future will be born.
That new world is yours to live in.
Not you guys all say F.
Not the grunting.
Gosh, like father like son.
So real.
We all fought a long bloody war for our liberty.
We fought to free ourselves from nations and systems and norms and ages.
But no matter how hard we tried, the only liberty we found was on the inside.
Trapped within those limits.
The boss and I may have chosen different paths, but in the end, we were both trapped inside the same cage.
Liberty.
Why is he trying to stand up again?
But you... you have been given freedom.
Freedom to be... outside.
It's like son... he's finally outside of the system.
You are nobody's tool now.
No one's toy.
You are no longer a prisoner of fate.
Kind of is.
I mean, he's a prisoner.
You are no longer a seed of war.
It's time for you to see the outside world with your own eyes.
Your body and your soul are your own.
Forget about us.
Live for yourself.
Snake, help him!
A new lease on life.
He's like, you want me to get that?
Boss, you only need one snake.
No.
The world needs snakes.
This is good, isn't it?
It's too good.
It's so good.
Yeah, the ending is so bittersweet.
This whole game is so bittersweet.
I wish to rest forever.
I have to ask if there was a...
I would rather how many people were in here watching the ending for the first time.
The graveyard character.
Yeah, I know a lot of people.
It's just not as cool to watch him clean up the bodies.
Me and my first time.
First time ever.
It's been 10 years since he played.
So it's been a while.
First timer.
I've watched the scenes a couple times.
It's a bit of an understatement, but it's still so good.
Man.
I hope you guys liked it though.
I have popcorn all over me.
A police knots and snatcher.
MGS series, the proof that men will never understand women.
Eva was right there.
She could have stopped them.
Eva knew what the boss wanted and she didn't do anything.
Yay, to all the staff.
If anything, it's a really beautiful game too.
Especially for the PS3 era.
It looks so good.
It holds up so well, even to now.
Here's to Naomi.
The graphics are insanely good.
Beauty and the Beast photo shooting session.
The actual models.
I know some people have probably said this in the chat, but in case some people didn't read...
In the Japanese version of this last scene...
The big boss is voiced by Akiya Otsuka's actual father.
And they were actually estranged.
This project kind of helped bring them back together.
Even in Japanese, I think it hits that even harder.
Amazing, right?
It's so good.
Spooky graphics!
It's a little too peak.
It's so awesome, right?
This song.
My playthrough was with friends who were ruining the moment, so I never got to experience any of the motion of the story.
Oh no!
Of course we can make jokes, but...
At the same time, I feel...
Some of those scenes are just too...
I can't even joke at them.
I can't even joke.
What?
Is that a hook, papa?
It really is?
Oh my gosh.
What a good ending.
You know, like I've said before...
The game has its flaws.
And I saw someone super chat earlier how the game was probably supposed to be a redemption for Naomi, but they just kind of really flubbed it up.
I don't even think she really needed redemption.
Like, she wasn't bad in the first game.
It was...
But, you know, despite all the silliness in some parts of the game, I still think that it's like...
It's still just such a good ending for Snake.
And so I think that's why, in my opinion, it's...
It's a really good end to the series, too.
I wouldn't mind this game getting the same treatment as MGS3 with a remake.
I think they would take out way too many things.
I think, like...
A lot of the IP stuff...
Like iPod and the songs, maybe.
Things like that.
I don't know if... I think that too much stuff would be removed for it to work.
I think, you know, if it can get ported, that's great.
Honestly, like...
Delta doesn't really need to happen.
It's cool that it is.
Don't get me wrong, but...
But, like, Metal Gear Solid 3 didn't need a remake either.
I would... I... You know, it's probably...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Meow.
There's nothing inside you can pass on to the next generation.
No genes.
No memes.
You're man-made.
You're a beast.
I thought turning off the notice would turn off the things.
I'm sorry.
Exactly.
That's why you need me.
As a witness.
A witness?
Yeah.
Someone on the outside to bear witness to your final days.
Tell your story.
Someone to pass on your story.
Not that I'm the only witness.
But I'll remember everything you were.
And stick with you to the end.
Otacon.
Besides, you wouldn't let me suffer Sunny's eggs alone, would you?
Oh my god, she knows how to cook them now!
Sunny catching strays.
For what reason?
That's when Otacon wrote his Twin Snakes fanfic.
Eggs.
She just put that on the grill.
And she said it's ready.
This song actually has Japanese lyrics to it.
Thanks for sharing the series with us.
Thank you!
Random Collusion, thank you so much for the Aqua Super.
Thank you.
Wait, I'm trying to read it.
Oh gosh, it's all getting... Oh gosh, YouTube is so broken.
I'm trying to click it.
There we go.
Long time watching, man.
Thanks for going through this journey again.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Twin Snakes next?
I'm already playing the Twin Snakes.
I already did it.
No, I've already played Twin Snakes.
Also, for the person who donoed earlier.
Yeah, I will play Rising again.
Don't worry.
But next is Peace Walker.
Then we got Five.
Rising.
I don't know when I'll do Rising.
Maybe after the Solid series.
I still have Snake's Revenge.
I still have Acid.
Still have Survive.
I guess Portable Ops.
We gotta do all of them.
I have to have every single game on my channel.
Yeah, Metal Gear 1 and 2.
Pachinko.
Pachinko?
I already played that.
I already played that too.
I have that.
We're still so far.
We have so many driven points I need.
I need...
I didn't know you turned it off.
Oh, sorry!
I turned it off because I didn't want the sounds going.
But thank you Haizmi for the Aka dono.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Always a treat to watch you play MGS.
Here's to you, Minto.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
I always, every time I play this game.
Or like, rather, when I think about how I play the games.
Like, rather, when I'm like, okay, I'll play 1 through 4.
And then I'll play in release order.
I always think like, man, I should have played this one last.
Even after everything.
It's like, this one should have been last.
You know?
Because it's just so...
It's just, you know, it does wrap up so well.
It is so final.
Yeah, it feels like the final game for sure.
It's so good.
Man.
So...
Have you gotten the board game?
I have!
I haven't played it.
I haven't even actually unboxed it.
It's still in the box.
But yeah.
You don't have to get emotionally invested in 5.
Would I eat a pigeon?
What?
No!
Scorpion.
Inchworm.
Hyena.
Hawk.
Eagle.
The title were to experience weapon handlers who racked up their heads so I can't...
I'm a gamer!
No way!
Really?
That's why I got Eagle!
I'm a gamer.
Oh my gosh.
We have to go try it.
The solar gun!
The weapon of a holy knight.
Uses the power of the sun to banish darkness.
While holding the L1 button, hold the R1 button to charge it, then release it to fire.
There are two levels of charge.
The longer the weapon is charged, the more powerful the shot.
Press the triangle while aiming to use the side.
Press the O to recharge it with solar energy.
Wait.
Items you obtain will become available after you meet up with... Oh gosh.
The Mark II.
We got it though!
Oh yeah, we can use it in the VR shooting range.
True, true, true.
New save.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, we'd have to do all of Act 1 exactly.
We can do it in the VR area.
Yeah.
Now,
you can have a new appreciated...
Appreciation rather for the...
For this...
Title screen.
Since it's literally the end of the game.
You can even see him get the gun out.
And then like, you know...
Snake...
Actually in the novel...
For those curious what happens afterwards, but...
The novelization of the 4 says that...
Snake spends his days with...
Spends the rest of his days with Otacon and Sunny.
And he passes away peacefully.
With a smile on his face.
Next to them.
It's novel only in Japanese.
No, actually, it has been translated.
There's an official translation even.
So...
Virtual range.
And all this happened because Volgin shot a nuke.
It's kind of insane, the...
The series of events that...
Took place to get to, like...
How insane everything is in this, like...
Seeing what's going on in 3...
And then getting to 4...
Is like...
The leap is so insane.
Actually.
Let's see.
Solar Guard!
There it is!
What
is he saying?
Wait, hold on.
What was it again?
Oh, press...
Wait, no, no, no.
Circle!
Satellite!
Hold on, I'm getting the energy lower.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait!
This is all I ever wanted!
It's all I ever wanted!
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
Strike!
Satellite!
Go!
Time to eradicate them.
Strike!
Satellite!
Let's put on something happy.
Wait.
Menu.
Wait, how do I go back?
Oh gosh, I don't know how to use the iPod.
Menu?
Wait, no.
Menu, menu.
Songs.
Satellite!
It was worth it!
This song is so cute.
Satellite!
Strike!
And this
thing does mega damage.
It's crazy.
Satellite!
And one more with my favorite song.
One more with my favorite song.
Oh wait, we're off.
This song is like an Astro Bomb BGM.
That's so mean.
Thank you for the meme.
I wish any of these guys would dance.
Snake!
It's now my turn to protect you, Snake.
Surely I'd be bigger.
I'd be like...
It's my turn to protect you, Snake.
I'd
be like this big next year.
It's my turn to protect you, Snake.
I wonder how tall he is, actually.
Thank you guys for MGS4.
Charge at the screen.
Satellite!
If I shoot...
No!
Turn around, Snake.
Wait, hold on.
I don't want any of these guys in our background.
Wait, no, no, no.
Sorry, my bad.
I'm getting the thing down.
The battery.
There we go.
Alright.
Ready, Snake?
Together, together!
Together, together, together!
Ready?
Satellite!
Why
Metal Gear Solid 4?
We'll get Two-Piece Walker eventually.
Oh yeah, there was someone to say happy birthday to.
Who was it?
Kenjo!
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Kenjo!
Sorry it took me so long to sing.
Happy birthday to you!
Okay.
I have another stream in about an hour.
So, I have to vacuum my room.
Because I got popcorn and I gotta change my dress.
Because I got popcorn all over it.
Thank you, Minto.
I still feel so...
I didn't mean to do that.
I meant to go back to the menu.
I still feel so many emotions.
But...
I love Metal Gear.
I love Metal Gear!
We know.
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted vectors!
Thank you.
I hope you guys enjoyed 4 also.
Gosh, it's almost been 4 and a half hours.
It doesn't feel like that at all.
I feel like I could go through it all over again.
I have more tears to cry!
It's a hell of a ride.
Man...
I just realized I didn't put on my headband.
I forgot.
Hold on.
Actually, I realized this too.
Watch this.
Look at this.
I think I forgot to put it on last time too.
Because I just get so...
Look, look, look.
Ready?
Hold on.
Let me scoot over.
I can do this.
Okay, hold on.
Let me move it down.
I can wear it properly!
But it's so weird!
I can wear it...
It's like bouncing on my head.
I can wear it properly!
Maybe.
If I wear it down...
How low can you go?
I can wear it properly.
Oh wait, it's kind of like a little...
There we go.
Only this is like a newer feature of Youtube Studio, so...
I never thought to do it before.
And then I tried it the other day and I was like...
I have to do this on stream!
But it's kind of weird because the tie is now like...
Not...
But it's so awesome, right?
It's not perfect, but it works, I think.
It's so funny.
I was like, wait...
I could have done this.
It's close enough, right?
It looks good.
Welcome to the future.
I'm scared.
Can I request that you wear the headband?
It's bald, Minto.
I wonder what would happen.
I'm scared.
3, 2, 1!
It's weird!
Okay.
What's up, Minto, everybody?
She became zero.
No!
And soon we'll be a swagger.
And...
Thank you, guys.
Sorry.
Also, I should say...
I'm really sorry, again.
My freak out at the beginning of the stream.
I've been going through it a little bit, but we're okay.
And we made it through.
And we...
We persevered.
And if you don't know what I'm talking about, don't worry about it.
Yeah, we persevered.
It was funny?
Are my mental breaks funny to you?
That's okay.
You can laugh at me.
I'm here for the entertainment.
Everybody, point and laugh!
At the ghost, she's having a mental breakdown.
Anyway...
What was I gonna say?
I don't remember.
Anyway, okay.
If I see you in a bit, I'll see you.
And if not, then I'll see you the next time I see you.
Thank you, guys.
Bye-bye.
Bye -bye.
This is today's ending song.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-bye Bye-bye!